[Music]
resident evil 7 launches next week and
when it does you'll be able to buy it
digitally for xbox one or PC and gain
access to the game on the other platform
but this isn't going to work with the
version you'll find on Steve I'm Matt
and this is your cross-platform gamespot
news update resident evil 7 is a part of
the play anywhere program we're buying a
game digitally on Xbox one get you a
Windows 10 version of the game and vice
versa this also means you'll be able to
transfer all of your progress gamerscore
achievements and extra content between
the two platforms the game is also
available on Steam but that version
won't feature cross-buy with the Xbox
one the next entry in Capcom's seminal
horror series releases on january 24th
for playstation 4 xbox one and pc you
can play a demo called the beginning our
right now and you don't have to worry
about spoilers because it's a completely
separate experience you'll even get an
item that can be transferred to the full
game as you complete the demos
complicated puzzle for more news from
the world of video games stay tuned to
gamespot
you